once a year members of the Israeli
Volkswagen enthusiasts Club come from
all over the country to meet here in
netanya the VW beetle is loved here and
around the world even so these owners
know the darker history about how the
car came about and that the car was once
seen as a symbol of Nazi Germany in
Israel normally I'd leave it alone I'm
not worried about it Hitler wanted to
build a brilliant car the fact that he
hated Jewish people and killed them
doesn't mean the car isn't a great car
you Maddy but not everyone thinks this
way according to recent surveys about 5%
of Israelis boycott German products in
general 50 years ago when the first
Beatles began to arrive in Israel
anti-german sentiment was high and not
just towards Beatles this quarter stood
there were a lot of protests back then
the first volkswagen beetles are a good
example there was strong opposition to
their sale at Santa oh what a call when
new buses were bought from mercedes-benz
then the Mercedes emblem had to be
removed the bull and falafel the
symbolism played a very big role in but
today many beetle owners believe that
driving the iconic car is a personal
statement that represents a different
Germany we are surrounded by
things that are made in Germany so we
can't you know say the history of the
car is like this so i'm ignoring the car
it's such a popular and the beautiful
car the VW beetle has become a cultural
icon in Israel even if the car does
carry a lot of historical baggage